I actually had a copywriting client a
couple years ago rob me of over $33,000
in commission. He reached out to me
through a mutual friend and asked if I
can write a bunch of ads and emails and
things like that to sell their
e-commerce product. We signed an
agreement, all that stuff, and I ended
up blowing it out of the water, way
beyond this guy's expectations. And he
freaked out and when it was time to pay
up the commission, he was basically
like, "Oh, I didn't I don't have the
margins in my e-com product to pay you
this much commission. I I genuinely
didn't expect that you were going to do
this. I hired six other agencies and
they have never gotten a performance
like this and then, you know, this
random guy on the internet that writes
copy blows it out of the water." So, he
doesn't end up paying me a dollar. I
actually end up hiring a lawyer. I send
legal documents, I sue this guy, and it
doesn't end up working out because he
lives in a different country and they
have different bylaws, so he didn't have
to respond to any of the legal stuff,
which was just absolutely crazy because
it was small claims court under 50,000,
whatever it is. So, I'm shafted out of
$33,000
from this guy, never hear from him
again, never even hear from my friend
who connected us, which is, you know,
very odd. And it just taught me this
lesson, this lesson where I'm like, I'm
sitting here thinking back and I'm like,
"Man, I could have like worked on my own
business, continued building my own
list, selling my own stuff, and that
would have made probably about the same
amount of money with all of the work
that I put into that, and instead, I
spent more time building this guy's
business who never ended up paying me a
dollar." Not everybody is crooked out
there, but nobody is going to take care
of you like you. Nobody's going to
invest in you like you. And so, this is
just a reminder that no matter what
industry you're in, you need to be in
your industry. SM me 500. You need to be
building your business, your email list,
selling your stuff, because you will
never shaft you.